she is at Brit on every social service
because well she doesn't sleep much and
is it early adopters an early adopter
extraordinaire so she's got me beat by
way better Twitter I was used her like
2,800
what were you I I had Evan biz signed me
up on my blackberry when it was an SMS
service so man who knows I was a pager
number after I was originally Jason
Calacanis and then I realized how
powerful it was gonna be and I had a
little sit-down with Jason hey Jason I
had to negotiate to get out Britt on
Instagram because I was on my first lady
and in the beginning path and Instagram
were a little yeah I was located yes I
was like I'm not gonna join that service
I told I missed my opportunity to be
Britt this girl from Columbia who's
obsessed with Justin Bieber was Britt I
was in Spanish trying to talk to her
negotiating in her comments for the name
like whatever Austin arrow I ended up
meeting Scooter Braun Justin Bieber's
manager and was like scooter you gotta
get me this Instagram handle what can we
do or like give her some sneakers like
what comes it can just go yeah right
like just like DM gets yeah easily and
he was like we'll figure it out let's
work it out it was gonna this is all
happening this is all the other social
media head oh and this is very important
I can't even tell the stories what I did
to get certain domain names and handles
really oh my god having children later
cuz that was the whole thing
Josh's immediate but um anyways the next
week her account randomly wasn't it
oops and I wonder how about now Kevin I
don't know I don't know honey the fixes
in you get me Britt right now perfect so
it happened